des airs de musique entraînant et
enivrant le conte la belle et la bête
était mise en musique à la batterie de
guyancourt sur scène quatre instruments
flûte hautbois violoncelle et accordéon
donc ce qui donne des timbres très très
particulier et est vraiment très riche
aussi on est sur une adaptation du texte
de madame leprince de beaumont qui a été
mis en musique par diane bezan et
frédéric unterfinger et c'est déjà une
adaptation du texte pour concorder avec
la musique un récitant vient accompagner
la musique le texte est en symbiose avec
les quatre instruments de musique
[Musique]
là bas je suis pas particulièrement de
musiciens donc évidemment il a fallu que
j'écoute particulièrement le travail de
mes collègues pour être sûr qu'on puisse
être bien ensemble et puis après c'est
vraiment un travail de partitions donc
c'est exactement comme au trail de
musiciens les mots sont écrits sur la
partition sur les notes quasiment tous
les musiciens viennent de saint quentin
en yvelines comme lobbyiste et le
flûtiste qui sont professeurs dans
l'école de musique de guyancourt ce soir
là une centaine de spectateurs étaient
présents j'ai beaucoup aimé ce spectacle
parce que j'ai trouvé que la mise en
musique avec le narrateur créé à un
moment vraiment magique ce spectacle
j'ai trouvé absolue vraiment magnifique
on était absorbé dans l'histoire
emporter par la musique mais quatre
instruments se mariait vraiment
superbement les musiciens de la belle et
la bête espère pouvoir rejouer ce
spectacle dans les mois à venir pour de
nouveaux publics
[Musique]